welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy that's
keeping you on track while snowpiercer
goes up the rails the fourth episode of
the season has just dropped and if it
left you confused then this video is
just the ticket so sit back whilst we
open up the drawers on what's going on
in the show throughout this video not
only will it be the worst puns ever
there's also gonna be a full breakdown
of the latest entry whilst we give our
thoughts on what exactly is happening
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yet then I highly recommend that you
check out right now if you enjoy the
video then please consider subscribing
as we do breakdowns on the show every
week and please drop a thumbs up as it
massively helps us out without the way
thank you for clicking this but let's
get into a breakdown of snowpiercer
episode four okay so the episode opens
from the POV of Jinju one of the most
mysterious characters in the show as she
prepares a fish dish for Beth we watches
the serial killer stands in the room
where he's just slaughtered Mickey Jay
jin-joo gives the history of Wilfred and
confirms that she's a scientist and this
is likely why she's so far up the Train
as she's instrumental in keeping it
running though we have thought that she
may be aware that melanie is secretly
masquerading as the mechanical Meckler
maniac she refers to Wilfred as if he's
still running things so I'm not even
sure anymore whether she's in on the
conspiracy or not of the opening so far
probably thinking this one is the
weakest as there wasn't really much to
take from it and it pretty much just
acts as an intro for the sake of it it's
kind of like how I have to force myself
to write these terrible puns in my
introductions for these videos and hey
they don't always work out as we saw
from the start of this video after the
titles in the quote unquote
engine room we see Bennet going to meet
Melanie I love how the room is adorned
with red tape which as we see in the
intro symbolizes the journey that the
train goes on as this is the room where
all the decisions are made it makes the
most sense to have this iconography here
Melanie one small where's an MIT hoodie
but we can also see that she wears a cap
that looks like it says Yale engineering
so the engine room
might actually be short for the
engineering room and it is possible that
Melanie is actually an engineer we know
that she isn't really well furred so in
order to be this far up the Train she
would likely have to have had occupied a
prominent position in a life before it
so Melanie has likely taken the
hospitality position in order to spy on
the lower parts of the vessel whenever
there's been something to fix onboard
snowpiercer she normally deals with it
firsthand and in this interaction she
discusses a methane problem on board so
she's very much enveloped in the
mechanical side of things so taking all
of this information I actually believe
that Melanie was likely an engineer that
worked at the front and then overthrew
Wilfred to take power
she also divulges that she was born on a
dirt farm and came from nothing so do
you think that we can finally put the
melanie is actually wilfred theories to
bed now Beth in Jinju discuss the former
taking up train and it's interesting to
see how the class systems of
relationships are still confined by the
rules of a society that no longer exists
more pressing matters arise when Niki
J's body is discovered and this was
found by Henry I don't know I don't know
why the hell I kept calling him Clint in
the video last week I'm sure I heard
them call him that but hey I guess you
miss yet things when you get up at 5:00
a.m. on a Monday to do a YouTube video
for about 20 people I'm just kidding I
love you and thank you for sticking with
me as well now Layton in the brakeman
realized that the killer is slightly
still in third due to the borders being
closed in the wake of fight night it's
not too long before the hunt is on and I
love that as they were going over the
details of the carriages commander great
ol Layton to give his eyes up obviously
they don't know that Layton is trying to
make a map of the train so that the tale
can start their revolution so this was a
nice little conversation that shows grey
is aware of just how bad things could go
should the tale discover it the tale of
course vastly overpopulate 3rd 2nd and
1st and should they start a revolution
it will likely go one way this of course
mirrors real-world events right now in
which we see a vast majority of people
protesting the authoritarian figures in
society the tale are seeking a quality
much like those protesting are and as
we've all seen the people in power don't
- interested in their plight I don't
want to derail the video even if I am
dropping some crap puns but I did
appreciate these moments
snowpiercer has always been laced with
political subtext and seeing it go
throughout these tiny little
interactions really hammers home just
how good the show is Audrey even tells
light in that she does want to see
change and thus this adds more weight to
the theory of third and the tail joining
one another in order to fight those
above them in the tail at Josie and cope
or over the access chip that was
smuggled out through Layton during the
episode she sneaks up through the cars
in order to get in contact with Layton
and though they're often brushed over
the tail definitely continue to provide
an interesting aspect of the plot
another interesting thing that mirrors
our world is that as she moves up
through the trains the temperature is
taken to see if she has any diseases and
she's then cleaned this is of course
being put in place at most airports
right now in order to stop coronavirus
up train Layton goes to first and passes
several famous paintings including
sunflowers by Van Gogh and the girl with
the Pearl Earring it's often been argued
that the Pearl Earring is actually a
piece of tin and many have gone back and
forth over whether it symbolizes wealth
or poverty trying to portray wealth it's
you see air could be how those in first
act all high and mighty like they're
better than everyone else but when you
see what they actually have it's very
little sure they possess fine clothing
and artwork but in terms of how it
actually improves their life it becomes
meaningless they all seem to distrust
one another whereas the tale don't and
on the whole their lives offer very
little to the economy and life on the
train in fact if you've seen the film
then you'll know that the tale provides
an essential service whereas first
really doesn't that's kind of how I took
this paintings usage but it probably
means nothing and I'm just reaching hey
look we'll have to make these videos 10
minutes somehow right anyway in first
Layton runs amok and immediately
realizes that the bodyguards are missing
LJ throws hers under the bus or rather
train and I think this hints early on
that she was behind the whole thing they
also talked about how he had a gun which
I remember seeing earlier in the series
LJ did tell him
put it away as we thought guns aren't
allowed on snowpiercer and this
disarmament was put in place to make the
tail Hannover their weapons however it
turns out that first didn't and I guess
it's one rule for the elite and another
one for everyone else realizing that
their bodyguard is of no longer use the
Folgers demand to speak to mr. Wilford
and if you've been following our
breakdowns you'll know that we think
that they're already aware that Wilford
isn't running the Train however I think
I might actually have been wrong on that
theory I do you think that it's just LJ
that knows the truth and this is why
they don't speak to him on the phone
Melonie calls their bluff on asking for
Wilford and thus they're allowed to
investigate the Folgers cabin here they
find a j-hook for beekeeping that we
actually learned was used by LJ to
castrate Erik the killer Layton
discovers the truth about her commanding
him to kill people and it's clear that
he was at the whim of at every beck and
call he also meets a cat called snow
Peter which puts my puns to shame I must
admit they discuss how fear is a weapon
and in the same way that the tale of
thought of its cannibals she is using
the killer to drive fear into those in
first the two agreed to make a deal to
help the tale but Layton sells her out
and LJ has locked away
however she likely knows the truth about
Melanie from the victims all being
connected to Wilford and I think it
would totally turn the show on its head
if it came out LJ will have visitors and
that she'll be able to tell everything
she knows about what's really going on
so Melanie will likely be put in a
vulnerable position as she will have to
cover up the truth should LJ know it all
whilst keeping up the facade that things
aren't descending into chaos Melanie
does something drastic at the end of the
episode which we'll talk about in just a
bit but yeah it looks like things are
going to be out in the open very soon
elsewhere we joined Josie and I think
the train passes the Grand Canyon at one
point and she sneaks about whilst on a
break from the sanitation work here she
meets with an ally that was moved up
from the tail and together they devise a
plan to help one another she agrees to
pass on a message to Leighton and even
share some of her food one tail one go
[Music]
one soul one that's dumb sorry I'll stop
the killer is also caught in the market
car and he runs and eggs Jinju hostage
Jinju discovers it was a girl commanding
him by the language he uses so it
probably was a smart move by lighting to
sell LG out however he was still doomed
to whatever Melanie had in store and the
episode ends with her drugging him and
locking him away in a drawer obviously
he's not going to be trapped forever as
well I've seen the trailer and I know
he's not but there's also a clue in the
intro I think in that we can see a body
sliding out of a drawer and I think this
symbolises him waking up now when this
will happen we don't offer definite but
he will eventually get out and thus the
secret will too
you just can't put all your problems in
a drawer and lock them away Melanie but
I can see the strategy behind it she
could just tell those in first second
and third that Layton had returned to
the tail and she could also tell a tale
that he'd just ended up living in third
however she doesn't know that the tail
know about what's going on and so I
think that the revolution is actually
gonna come really soon in order to set
him free it would be crazy if that
happened in the next episode old even
just the one after it but yeah I do
think that things are gonna kind of be
flipped upside down very soon anyway
that's a big mystery over with and I was
actually surprised at how early we got
answers in the series over the killer I
think the attention will now turn to
keeping Melanie's secret secret and
slowly more and more people are starting
to learn about it again this was a
brilliant episode and I'm really loving
the show right now the first four have
been great and I'm so glad that it's
going full steam ahead rather than
picking up late on a late on yeah cuz
the names late late on anyway obviously
I loved hear your thoughts on the 3rd
episode and you know what you're
thinking of the series so far comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video yeah just just hit the like
button and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the series so far if you've
missed any episodes we've gone over the
first three and given our fan theories
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have
due to being with a chance of winning
the marble face report - box set is
leave a like leave a comment and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support us from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on I discord server link below or a
heavy spoilers on Twitter hope you see
over there very soon and thank you for
sticking with me until the end of the
video take care this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you